in your writing a biography
autobiography so I'm gonna steal a
c-span question
Ivan watched the post and they
interviewed Katharine Graham years ago
and she wrote a tell-all book about the
post and her family and the troubles
with her husband and his depression
things like that and the interviewer
said why do you want people to know this
she said good question I started and I
was only gonna tell one thing and I just
I kept going I couldn't stop I'm writing
this book for all the losers in the
world for all the people that have been
told you cannot do it you're a loser or
too stupid you're too ugly or to a dummy
or too black you're too whatever you're
never gonna make it
I've been called all those things and
worse I'm writing this book because I
want children who are going through
similar things and never give up on
themselves I can get through it so can
you
never never whether you're 5 or 100
never give up it's never too late you
determine your reality are there forces
that help shape that context around you
of course there are I mean but what is
your responsibility because the
boogeyman's bigger than you you don't
you don't fight back you don't do
nothing you don't buy this toy you don't
do nothing you just talk about the size
of the book in the hand how long it's
been on your neck the color of the
boogeyman
the boogeyman insists
the boogeyman's how can we say the order
of his breath you can describe every
aspect of the boogieman for the rest of
your damn life or you can buy this top
now ya ain't gonna kill with you buy
this - but tolls are sensitive there's
gonna be some movement well he needs a
little bit a little bit but you're not
gonna bite
well that's your definition of your
possibilities in life I can't bite
because the boogeyman so big and I'm so
weak goodbye sorry not me never you
gonna have
my guess a couple of bullets they were
to hit something that's vital cuz they
can remove them I'm coming back never
give up never and as I feel me was to
say to the people who try to stop you
and put you down there's only one phrase
that they deserve and that is this -
dumb as you look
my name is damn dumb as you look
when you keep talking I want you to know
something - dumb as you look
you know it's interesting once they see
that who Ortiz they know that you're not
playing checkers in a chess game you're
playing chess my mom was a both playing
chest let's play so I got some damn
moves - lets just play don't tell me how
good a checker player I am
that's why I feel